last night was night three of the
democratic national convention and
former president barack obama gave what
was by all reasonable assessments a very
solid dnc speech in support of joe biden
and kamala harris and
very strongly going after donald trump
and barack obama i mean listen you don't
have to think he was the best president
you don't have to think that joe biden's
the best candidate but barack obama did
not show up with kid gloves in
criticizing donald trump you're going to
see clips in a moment but donald trump
within minutes if not seconds of barack
obama's speech starting
was completely and instantly triggered
starting to send out outrageous tweets
in all caps
more the behavior of a child really than
an adult never mind an adult who happens
to be the president of the united states
you can imagine the scene trump sitting
at the white house
obama comes up on his screen and starts
dismantling donald trump pointing out
his failings and his
fundamental lack of capacity for the job
piece by piece by piece
trump grabs his phone
turns on caps lock as so many trumpists
often do when it's time to tweet and
then tweets
he spied on my campaign and got caught
referring i guess to the supposed
biggest political crime in history which
i can't even say it with a straight face
which we still haven't gotten the
details of or been able to identify and
then just moments thereafter as barack
obama continues speaking in full
sentences and putting together coherent
thoughts which is a very uh unusual
thing from a president at this point in
time trump tweets again with capslock
still engaged why did he refuse to
endorse slow joe until it was all over
and even then was very late
why did he try to get him not to run
so the second part why did obama try to
convince joe not to run
that's bs
but the reason barack obama decided not
to endorse joe biden or anybody during
the primary was the calculation and
arguably it's a politically astute
calculation that if barack obama gets
involved in the primary
and then whoever he supports doesn't end
up being the nominee
it could end up being divisive and it
could end up hurting barack obama's
ability to then endorse and campaign for
the eventual nominee it's a political
calculation you can disagree with it or
not but that's all it is barack obama's
priority was and is to defeat donald
trump and barack obama made the call
he's a better
player in that cause by staying out of
the primary
and getting involved in support of the
eventual nominee which is what he did
there's really nothing controversial
there but if you want to go in that
direction we should ask the question
why hasn't george w bush gotten involved
at all in helping donald trump get
reelected and of course george w bush is
not supporting trump in the sense of
publicly as we've heard in a statement
from a staffer of george w bush is and
certainly is not helping donald trump
get reelected what about that that is a
question that should be asked now barack
obama's speech
was followed
during night three of the dnc
by vice presidential pick kamala harris
democratic senator from california and
donald trump also triggered by her and
tweeting erratically
still with the caps lock engaged saying
quote but didn't she call him a racist
referring to kamala and joe biden didn't
she say he was incompetent
some clips
from barack obama's speech
that
went right after donald trump this is
probably
part of the a moment that most triggered
donald trump
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
and the consequences of that failure are
severe
170 000 americans dead
millions of jobs gone
well those at the top taken more than
ever
our worst impulses unleashed
our proud reputation around the world
badly diminished
and our democratic institutions
threatened like never before
obama treating trump almost like a
little kid saying i you know i had hopes
that he would
take the jobs it's like the the the
hopes were so pathetically low
people were hoping trump would take the
job seriously and he didn't
people were hoping trump would grow into
the job
and he didn't and then barack obama
continuing
i never expected that my successor would
embrace my vision
or continue my policies
i did hope
for the sake of our country
that donald trump might show
some interest in taking the job
seriously
that he might come to feel the weight of
the office and discover some reverence
for the democracy that had been placed
in his care
but he never did
for close to four years now he has shown
no interest in putting in the work
no interest in finding common ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office to help anyone but himself
and his friends
also going after the trump
administration on the basis of their
playing
very fast and loose with democracy work
will continue long after this election
but any chance of success depends
entirely
on the outcome of this election
this administration has shown it will
tear our democracy down
if that's what it takes for them to win
so we have to get busy building it up
by pouring all our efforts into these 76
days so overall barack obama's speech
was fine it emphasized
donald trump's failings
uh and the constitution the weight of
the office of the presidency and the
responsibility that comes with it i
think it was a good speech
i actually think michelle obama's speech
on monday night
resonated more in terms of sort of
lighting a fire about the acute nature
of this situation the emergency of a
total deficit of morality and decency
and empathy in the white house so in a
sense certainly barack obama a master
orator michelle obama also a great
speaker but i actually thought that
overall maybe michelle obama's speech
was better suited for communicating the
urgency of the situation although listen
i miss hearing complete sentences from a
president we heard complete sentences
from barack obama this is how low the
bar is i miss hearing coherent thoughts
expressed in those complete sentences
and we heard some from barack obama and
you know we're really talking about
details now now last thing about the
obama speech
barack obama mentioned
that even when the democratic system
appears not to work
our ancestors our predecessors may be
better said
still managed to use those arguably uh
flawed systems successfully to affect
change this was this didn't get a lot of
attention from the speech it is so
poignant right now so i want to play
this is about 90 seconds from barack
obama's speech
listen very closely to what he says here
i think this is really crucial
what we do
echoes through generations
whatever our backgrounds we are all the
children of americans who fought the
good fight
great grandparents
working in fire traps and sweatshops
without rights or representation
farmers losing their dreams to dust
irish and italians and asians and
latinos told go back where you come from
jews and catholics
muslims and sikhs made to feel suspect
for the way they worshipped
black americans chained and whipped
and hanged
spit on
for trying to sit at lunch counters
beaten
for trying to vote
if anyone
had a right to believe that this
democracy did not work
and could not work
it was those americans
our ancestors they were on the receiving
end of a democracy that had fallen short
all their lives
they knew
how far the daily reality of america
strayed from the mid
and yet instead of giving up
they joined together
and they said somehow some way we are
going to make this work
we are going to bring those words
in our founding documents
to life
this is so key right now
because
we are trying to fix
a problem
with a system that we don't have huge
confidence in postal service voter
suppression
reducing our early voting all the stuff
we've been covering and we're saying we
have a real problem that we've got to
fix
but part of the problem needs to be
fixed with a system that is part of what
needs repair as well will a broken
system allow us to actually fix it
and barack obama very
um poignantly says presciently says if
anyone had a right to believe that this
democracy didn't work and could not work
it was our ancestors those americans who
were on the receiving end of a democracy
that fell short
and he said
they knew how far
the daily reality of america strayed
from the myth of america and they didn't
give up they didn't bail and say screw
it
they joined together and said let's
figure out how to make this work that
applies to this situation which is we
have to use a system that donald trump
has manipulated for his own gain to get
him out and the answer is
you know what i'm going to say
we have to so overwhelm the vote
that the ways trump has
fixed and by fixed i don't mean repaired
i mean uh uh sort of rigged
the election
will not be enough to put him in the
oval office for an additional four years
we have to figure out how to do that we
can use this system to remove trump we
just really have to come out in force
and a little bit later on we are going
to talk about how 2016's non-voters
are looking at this election very
interesting so that was night three of
the dnc join me tonight for night for
the final night of the dnc
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit
smoking and vaping by offering a clean
affordable nicotine alternative now
many of you know you've heard the
stories i've known several people in my
life who have struggled with quitting
smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be
and nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful lucy offers a nicotine gum in
three flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice flavor lucy is
affordable it'll ship right to your door
you don't have to go out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape and lucy can make it easier you'll
find a ton of excellent reviews online
from countless people who have used lucy
to quit smoking and vaping go check them
out at lucy.c
i've put the link right underneath this
video and you'll get 20 off when you use
the coupon code pacman and just a quick
disclaimer i'm required to give these
products contain nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical